reshooting this intro hey what's going
on there reject nation greg and aaron
back at it to watch umbrella academy
season three episode seven today aaron
are you excited i was born excited that
is i'm liking it okay
guys leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when i react for the next umbrella
academy is up we know stranger things is
coming out this weekend so you know
get ready to completely skip the rest of
the umbrella academy reactions by the
time that show comes out
and uh full length watch so long as we
sync up with the time code or over at
our patreon page become a super sexy
reject today by checking everything we
got to offer over there
also the prepper boys thank you for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's get to it
[Music]
now you be firm this time yes
that's the end of season two
oh
i get it
ding dong the [ __ ] is dead so make her
daughter pay instead not exactly fair
bars
i mean you did do some criminal
activities
tear that wall down
that's the heel
the heel academy
oh secret briefcase
that's the handler's logo look who found
mother's little escape plan that answers
that question whatever's chasing you
you're so smart of all the brain
is cells stanley's mom
i'm gonna assume it is
oh
snap
what
i was just tripping
no no he's really there
[Music]
are you rushing are you dragging
no i think she's taking out her emotions
on the drums all that frustration
i mean that's kind of like what punk
music really resembled thank you for the
history
[Laughter]
what do you say you and i go to america
and terrorize an old friend of mine
could be fun
i'm dumb
form an umbrella
yeah
oh man i wish i knew how to do that
and you remained dead for 22 minutes
totally vulnerable i could have taken
every one of your organs
what this guy's so sadistic
oh
we have work to do no death
actually you might be honest something
he needs to save the world
ben is calling a family meeting oh right
yeah good agreed both families
yeah you're right people to work
together
or being serious um
[Laughter]
or two sparrow academy the world's
ending so i think it's time to put our
petty [ __ ] aside and work together
on this cougar blitz yeah or what well
stanley won't be the last of us to
disappear
god damn that's logical
i feel like your answer's probably in
there
number five was trying to get into
why don't you guys all just go to the
hotel
instead of leaving where the solution is
sparrows go to the hotel
look i know there's been bad blood
between us whatever
bygones right
question yeah if i kill you do we get
our bend back
[Laughter]
what did you do to harlan
they didn't do anything
i did
i killed harlan you [ __ ]
tell him greg i don't understand why
because he didn't deserve to live
what
it's not your choice to make allison
have to listen to them
i screwed him up and if
you need someone to blame i'm right what
makes you think i don't
this wasn't about saving the world oh
man this was about hurting me
payback for
go on
say your name you know what maybe we
should all just take a minute okay
did killing harlan bring claire back
that's pretty cold do you know what that
felt like watching you fight harder to
protect the man who helped destroy my
daughter than you ever did to bring her
back i don't know how to bring claire
back thank you destroy the world kill
pogo almost kill me and for what so we
can all run around and clean up your
mess
i'm sick of it take it easy allison
[Laughter]
allison
see those eyes
yo
she has some stuff in her i got romney
are you doing this without saying i
heard a rumor just a little residual
gift
from harley all right that's it knock up
the power [ __ ] alison it's not okay
we should have left
in the business what the
[ __ ] allison oh my god you are such a
[ __ ] you're the worst
you okay
i'm fine
oh damn i think five's on her side
never mind then i'm announced inside
this one well that drama brought
everyone together
[Laughter]
in the wrong location
oh is this her old room
i think this is his old room
not the
yes my bad
try
[Laughter]
jennifer
[Music]
oh damn did ben lose someone oh maybe
that's why he's a dick
ah so ben didn't die in this one
ben lost someone ben died during the
jennifer incident tragic oh tragic i'm
not finished
you drugged your daughter
the jennifer incident i can't control
how long i'm dead it's just one of those
mystery of life things nonsense dying
well it's a skill like any other simply
need the right coach
do you trust me
yeah
i trust you
i don't know if i should trust him
do you just manipulate him so well yeah
stand there
when you're fast enough to catch this
ball you will have succeeded just so you
know i have the hand-eye coordination
drunk kitten
[Laughter]
1 15 p.m
do you not see that buster
[Laughter]
reanimation after death 18 minutes six
seconds
can he control ghost 2 or communicate
with him yeah [ __ ] they forgot about
that in this season
again
[Laughter]
oh my god this is where all the budget
went
[Laughter]
i think you're getting the hang of it
oh no oh god oh
oh oh no
[Applause]
[Music]
i love all these cars that are just
leaving
nobody stops
[Laughter]
this looks so freaky
[Music]
i'm really enjoying this episode a lot
yeah
i'm really enjoying it
[Music]
never trust a cyborg is she a cyborg or
she's just a robot
some type of android
confinement factor
0.98 at peak energy flux tensile
strength uts ceiling of 10 000
gigapascals should i be finding this
hall no
we need sloan
lyla christopher and victor
of course
way to go letting the world burn because
you're angry at your sister outstanding
that's not what i'm doing don't care
won't matter much longer anyway in a few
days we'll all be uh google toast guess
harlan will have died for nothing stop
crying on my bedsheets emo oh my god he
might have just motivated her
[Laughter]
paul still remaining a dick
impressive
here your gift became your nightmare you
lost something vital here it's time you
take it back
[Music]
i really hope this hargrave is a good
one
yeah it's making me like him
saying something what you doing
using its own gravity to condenser
it's pretty cool huh
what ben it is cool
oh no
oh no
he's gonna have problems with it
you didn't tell me you were building a
prison for god
um
you have no right
i still don't get why she's obsessed
with the
the google blicks because the commentary
on american industrialism and creating
technology
[Laughter]
oh my god that guy got me yeah
[Laughter]
face your demons
here you were saying they forgot about
this
it's diego don't make us hurt you ben
like tentacle or something man
five taker somewhere else
thank you jesus
oh
creepy
yep wow that is creepy it's not even
that's a
prosthetic
i look animatronic
five's having uh
oedipus complex right now
dolores
[Laughter]
it was no accident i made you children
feel small confused about your own
powers so that i could control you
what the [ __ ]
never
[Laughter]
i don't know but i believe with all of
my heart
that you do
be everything i was afraid to let you
become
okay
i like this a lot you [ __ ] how
dare you make me like you with your
psycho
analytics
whoa
awesome
right on klaus yeah
that's how we do
i really liked it
it was a very great episode
[Music]
couple wave in three two
one
[Music]
that whole process took them three hours
hey they're really bonding
two of their family members are still
dead
dance off your emotions
come on allison you know you feel it
[Music]
ah don't be a party pooper
damn the world's still [ __ ] up though
yeah but they saved it
everything's better now it's fine well
he just saved the world
you deserve to finally see it
okay so we gotta see what's going on at
this oblivion place now right
i um what
i made it myself i couldn't exactly find
a diamond done shortly homie you just
met her
son
[Music]
will you marry me yo
what
ridiculous man i don't know man this is
so fast i've seen the show love is blind
i'm on board for this
[Laughter]
the end of the world i respect mean yeah
i guess i'm the end of the world but
still man 20 days ago you're all about
that sister come on yeah try a couple
weeks love is blind
watch that also on netflix
i'm not going to be very good at this
mother thing apples and trees but i saw
you with stan and you'll get that
otherwise she's okay
[Laughter]
truth
i'm not pregnant
i think you should run for me
what damn
i think i'm a bloody mess and
i think that someone who's
never had a family this is my position
to ask for one
that's what i want
with you
oh that's sweet
can i think about it
yeah
of course
so you're saying there's a chance a
little bit of self-respect diego that's
good that's good
good job i thought i was going to swing
right into it give me a little
teary-eyed there
i was feeling some things there
people like us we will never
save enough lives to make up for the
ones that we take this is the price of
being powerful sometimes we step on ants
well
[ __ ]
no more going rogue
if you ever need anything i'm always
here for you
but lie to us again
victor i'll kill you myself
oh
blood we made peace
and i worked out
yeah
that's kind of working everyone in the
morning right bruh
and chris has dibs on knife boy no one
is killing anyone hey guys why not
we followed you our plan merge the
family save the world we don't need them
anymore i'm not done yet
done what that's between me and dad
what
you're a terrible leader with no loyalty
to anyone i'm number one you'll do as i
say what i say
not anymore
some real like cruel attention [ __ ]
[Music]
oh no what did you guys do
another sparrow down
[Music]
wow
sarah oh my god
that's terrifying oh my gosh [ __ ]
netball chills damn that was oh that was
like 1 million percent the best episode
of this season
thus far
[Laughter]
wow that fired on all cylinders man
listen we got a lot to
bottom lines like
normally we spend like 20 to 30 minutes
talking about these episodes but we got
a few more to go through so we don't
want to talk for too long
um because there's uh
more coming up this week that it has to
be covered so it's just it's very just
jam-packed so normally we obviously like
my favorite part is actually doing the
reviews and um unfortunately we just
can't really talk for too long so we'll
keep it relatively short but
um
aaron what did you think about this
episode oh man i thought this episode
was incredible from all the character
development we got to see from
uh
the highs and lows of each
relationship to
how this ended with things getting
significantly worse than what we just
saw yeah i think this is the strongest
one hands down that we've seen i really
liked last episode but yeah this episode
just continued to top the momentum of
where the show's going it started off
pretty rough and it broke the curse of
the odd episodes being kind of okay and
the evening episodes being good i'm like
no this is just
going full steam from here and i'm
really on board for it i really enjoyed
the klaus and hargrave stuff i thought
that was
was uh
something that started off like a little
like uh untrustworthy but then turned to
be really sweet and really thoughtful
i really enjoyed watching lila get to
bond with the family and like that diego
and lyla scene really touched me and got
me in an emotional place
yeah i like seeing them all celebrate
their their false victory for a second
like i like seeing the levity of this
family unite again
and
yeah just the tension moments felt very
real and authentic i really really vibe
with a lot of the stuff in this episode
yeah i think that what this episode
really gave that
i mean i was kind of saying this about
the i think around the fifth episode was
even though i overall have been enjoying
the season it hasn't particularly felt
exciting
and even though there's been some that i
thought were great exciting was never
the emotion i would ever associate with
any of the episodes
um even for the ones i really liked but
this one had it this one was really
exciting this was like a really exciting
episode and it still was very
character-driven and nuanced like the
development of hargraves and klaus and
especially with klaus getting too cause
it was kind of flashing to the beginning
of season two when they had the
apocalypse um flash forward when
everyone was like power unleashed and
klaus i remember had that moment where
he like unleashed the ghosts yeah and
i'm like we've never come close to
seeing him get to that level of power
yet and this kind of introduces that and
of him being able to do that and i like
this kind of back and forth that the
this episode gave us with hargraves of
do we trust this guy or not because
there seems to be a lot implying not to
and but he sells it so much on
keeping that sternness but sincerity
combined
that i believe he's genuine in the
moment and that he cares about klaus and
wants to do right but then i'm like i
don't know though you know there's been
other moments when the umbrella
academy's not around or the sparrow
academy for that matter that seemed to
indicate that he's still messed up but
he's got some other plan up his sleeve
and the fact that he's off his meds and
oblivion that we of course learned about
with pogo it just seems like there's a
there's a lot um
but even like i mean the thing that
kind of um allison frustrates me
at the same time i do kind of
get it
i i think ultimately i get it it's just
it's it's annoying
yeah i get it it's annoying that goes
for alison that goes for ben and i know
you're really vibing with i just feel
like the the
the luther stuff's happening way fast
man yeah i watch the whole so fast gotta
watch love is blind
do you know what this show is love is
blind it's like about people who
connect with one another without
actually seeing each other and then
meeting them like oh i love you and they
propose yeah and then there's a couple
of them won't say who who like still
years later are still married really
yeah wow
okay i mean what makes that show good is
unlike most reality shows
there's a pitch for if you haven't seen
what was blind unlike most rea i don't
watch i don't turn on reality shows i
don't i saw a commercial for it and i
had no idea i've never heard of this and
i hadn't it was this was like a few
weeks ago i had no idea about this show
and i saw a commercial
and and like on one of those netflix
previews and i was like what sounds
crazy and then i turn it on and it's it
can be so moving at times and unlike the
other reality shows it feels like real
and raw
a lot of some stuff feels like you
obviously told the actors that the
people that do some stuff but most of
the time like damn these are like real
conversations and men and women really
fighting in real tears from both sides
like it's crazy
so yeah to then see a couple of them who
are still like married after a few years
it's pretty awesome okay and they got
married pretty freaking fast
okay so with stakes like this
and with everything happening here i'm
like sure why not not that if we've seen
much of the development of the
relationship that's what i think is
missing is we haven't been it's just
kind of seemed like such early honeymoon
phase and i'm like there's there's not
really a depth to their dynamics
so
i'll say you sold me on love is blind
i'll probably
i really like that [ __ ] i'm all about
authentic connection yeah i don't know
like the first couple episodes i was
like these people are really falling
along each other
this is crazy these people are insane
um no i i go i get why you would feel
that way i mean because i think they
they filled in a lot of context no i'm
like grant do i think their chemistry is
really good yes i just think the fact
that
when the show started they they really
hammered home that this
just happened right after season two and
and it's only been 20 days for these
characters and then he's already
marrying this woman he's only known for
like a week but granted like you know
love does happen fast in in certain
contexts but yeah i think just the word
where we know him to be from the time
that the show started to where he is now
i'm like oh my god this is like
breakneck speed but definitely yeah yeah
i can't i can't i can't
fault that but i i think uh i don't know
maybe the whole thing with the end of
the world i i fill in a lot of [ __ ]
regardless i mean it doesn't it didn't
bother me
who cares um i like that and um i think
i i think like uh elliot page is such an
excellent i really really love what
elliot page is doing this season yeah
i'm very much drawn to his work uh more
than the other seasons i'm not sure what
it is in particular i mean it's like
there's
i like i guess i'm really i'm really
drawn to characters who
are
in i think that's what elliot page does
so well it's like internal struggles
and you know having to
try to keep things cool and and try to
do good things
but there's so much other [ __ ] happening
externally and internally and just can't
have i can't handle a balance all at all
and then to have the conversation with
five reflect that journey of trying to
create a balance
and and redemption but it's not going to
really be that case like i thought there
were some good philosophical discussions
about what it means to be a hero
and i thought there were some great
vulnerable moments like with lila and
diego
and
you know her just kind of confessing to
everything like i thought the dramatic
scenes really hit home very well
and it had that balance this funny
enough of the first episode that
discusses like trying to balance some
things out
this episode i thought had the balance
that i was sort of missing from umbrella
academy where you're like no these are
the scenes that are like exciting and
cool and like i love the whimsy of klaus
like dying over and over again and
getting better at it and facing his
fears like i'm bringing that back to
season one
and then uh you know like dealing with
the cougar blitz and watching the
sparrow work sparrows work together then
having some hard-hitting drama scenes as
well i'm like that's the umbrella
academy i mainly
remember is like doing all that
you know and so i thought this episode
was great this was this is a really
fantastic one
and uh yeah but we got to move on
thank you guys for being here thank you
aaron for being here i hope you start
love is blind i think you'd really
enjoyed
that was the biggest takeaway from this
episode watch love is blind it's really
good
[Laughter]
now there are times they're just like
holy [ __ ] this is so real
um because i know people who've like
worked on reality shows like the
bachelor and stuff so i know what like
what what can be like [ __ ] so
there's times where i'm like okay this
is definitely
that stuff is like kind of staged but
most of it is
gnarly
anyway okay i'll check it out i'm
serious i love the show you can tell
it's great
i know i've been wanting to watch season
two i haven't started season two yet oh
then it will react your react to season
two no no just for me just for me better
call saul and love is blind
just for me mary and barry just for me i
have some shows that are just for me
okay okay and the misses as well
anyway guys thanks for being here let's
end this with a patron
chase gardner john do you know what the
name chase means it means uh pure
oh god damn it john and not hold you you
know to look this up in my own mind
under my breath while you had headphones
oh there it is there's the notification
in my mic
you know what chase means it means to
pursue no that's what the
verb of case means do you know what the
pronoun chase means oh no it's a pronoun
i could more than the name was i'm not
using that right pronouns are like oh
[ __ ] i [ __ ] that up too it's the thing
i've never been stressed out about the
name you know what the name means you
probably don't why don't you enlighten
the both of you means hunter do you know
wow that's cooler than i said
you lucked out dude yeah
i guess it makes sense chase you hunt
things down the thrill of the chase now
chase what i want you to do next since
you're such a loyal super sexy reject
i want you to hunt down out first i want
you to kidnap every member of blind wave
i want you to throw them into the woods
unconscious nude
and then i want you to give them 30
minutes to hide and then you're gonna
hunt each one of them down so you get it
in the woods like a garden gardener
chase and you're hunting them
then i want you to kill blind wave and
bring them all to me
on their heads on a spike
but don't tell them i
said the shadow because they might not
they don't i don't think they actually
watch us so i i think we watch them way
more than they watch us so they won't
know that we're beings right now when
you're doing it if you could just shout
at some point that the real rejects
tried to stop you from doing this i
think that would really help only if you
think you're gonna fail on cutting their
heads off yes if there's any chance
they're walking away unscathed that
isn't a very important piece that's very
important we need an alibi you need to
be so thank you chase you have a great
pronoun
and i'm proud to have you here
[Music]